bonjour je suis ravi d'être là parmi
vous aujourd'hui pour moi c'est très
important d'être présent parce que je
crois vraiment à cette initiative
effectivement je suis multiculturelle je
suis né dans une famille très pauvre
j'ai fait un concours quand j'avais 17
ans et je les gagne et je suis rentré au
gong les gt la rédactrice photo la plus
jeune de l'histoire de condé nast à 17 à
19 ans j'étais à premier rang dans les
défilés de mode à vingt trois ans
j'étais rédactrice en chef mode je
faisais la couture j'avais envie de rêve
j'avais envie de luxe et un jour en 2002
j'ai décidé de tout quitter et de me
transférer au ghana et je vais vous
expliquer le pourquoi de mon histoire et
comment j'ai trouvé mon étoile polaire
quand je suis arrivé au ghana j'étais
volontaire avec ma fille dans un
orphelinat
c'est un endroit qui était sale
c'était un endroit où les enfants
mourront de maladies comme le paludisme
peut facilement
rires c'était un endroit où il y avait
des chambres rempli de donation
étrangers qui n'était jamais utilisée et
en même temps les bébé dormait par terre
son camp leur change leur couche c'est
un endroit non je faisais beaucoup d'
excuses je me disais je voulais croire
que les gens qui s'occupent des enfants
sont bons et qu'ils font ça parce qu'ils
sont gentils
donc je voyais tous ces choses qui a le
pain mais j'essayais d'excusés
j'essayais de matières l'europe sans eau
électricité tambour est au bout de 24
heures ici ces pauvres gens ils font le
mieux qu'ils peuvent
ils ont cinq enfants et pas de moyens
nous l'a fait je me suis trompé
c'est un doigt
n'étaient pas enregistrés c'est un
endroit qui était pas surveillé il n'y
avait pas d'assistance sociale
il n'y avait pas de papiers des enfants
il y avait beaucoup de volontaires comme
moi qui venais et qui travaillait avec
les enfants sans être surveillés
donc en fait ça pouvait être une porte
ouverte à la pédophilie mais la chose la
plus choquante de tout c'est que 90% des
enfants dans cet orphelinat n'étaient
pas orphelins
attention je dis bien 90% des enfants
n'étaient pas orphelins et ceux ci va
vous étonner mais c'est un chiffre qui
s'applique à tout le monde
il ya eu un nouvel rapport publié par
sève de tout jeunes qui nous a bien
confirmé que dans toutes les ombres
orphelinat donc tout le monde puisque
90% des enfants ne sont pas orphelins
ils ont des parents alors nous savons
que les enfants ils ont besoin d'un des
relations d'amour avec un adulte pour
grandir et devenir des adultes équilibré
pourquoi une société qui continue à
séparer les enfants de leurs parents
et pourquoi on trouve que c'est ok de
mettre les enfants en orphelinat comme
si c'était dans des garages 1 alors j'ai
commencé à penser que je devais faire
quelque chose parce que dans ma vie
quand j'avais 4 ans mon père est parti
il a laissé ma mère toute seule en
espagne
or qu'elle parlait pas espagnol et elle
pouvait pas l été et l'enseigné la
natation mais vous savez en espagne en
septembre il commence à faire froid et
la boue qu'ils travaillent donc il a
décidé de me faire accueillir par une
famille qui était beaucoup plus riche
que nous et l'amour de cette famille
elle n'a sauvé parce que je suis resté
avec eux pendant un an
le nom que ma mère chercher du travail
et en plus il se montre pour trouver en
course et j'ai eu un bourse à l'école
pendant 12 ans et donc cette famille
cette tendresse cette gentillesse avait
sauvé ma vie
et quand je me suis trouvé au face à ces
enfants qui étaient dans une situation
beaucoup pire que la mienne j'ai décidé
d essayer de faire la même chose pour
eux j'ai trouvé mon étoile polaire
incite même moulin une recherche qui est
sorti de cette d'étudiants et ils ont
beaucoup de travail sur le fait que les
orphelinats sont pas la bonne façon de
s'occuper des enfants abandonnés et il
ya eu cette recherche
et quand je les lui j'étais complètement
choqué parce que j'avais investi tout
mon argent donnant félina du coup je me
trouve cette recherche qui me dit vous
vous êtes trompés madame faut tout faire
et je savais bien que les donateurs et
mais bienvenu avoir des immeubles où il
avait bien mis leurs enfants et que vous
pouvez compter les petites et des
enfants qui étaient dedans
et pourtant du coup quand j'ai vu cette
recherche tout masculin a changé et j'ai
compris qu'il fallait changer qu'il
fallait aux aveux avant le courage de
faire des choses différemment et subaru
à partir de 2006 j'ai commencé à
travailler avec le gouvernement du ghana
pour fermer les orphelinats et on a
fermé le gouvernement du ghana a permis
de pousser moment 90 au féminin et ils
ont travaillé avec les assistant social
pour trouver d autres façons pour aider
des enfants parce que on sait très bien
que les enfants ils ont besoin de
grandir dans des familles pas dans des
orphelinats ou il ya des abus des
aliments ou des enfants bande annonce en
tout sont fermés
sable d un féminin ont souvent dû veuve
de la criminalité souvent déguisés
derrière des envies initiale de vraiment
aider des enfants et donc je ne
travaillerai pas avec le gouvernement du
ghana et je suis ravi parce que je
trouve que j'ai réussi à faire pour les
enfants
côté mon enfant ça qu'ils avaient fait
pour moi je trouve que la boucle est
bouclée
là nous qui avaient été démontrés envie
de moi j'ai plus le répéter c'est comme
si j'avais un kama parfait et c'est pour
ça que je considère qu'être de nous
battre pour cette transformation des
systèmes de ne parte pour que les
enfants grandissent en famille pour ne
pas que les fins seul pouvait ont élevé
leurs enfants
c'est le plus beau combat et c'est mon
étoile polaire merci